mike i know i've told you my stories
about julius peppers right before where
like the first time i ran on the field
at texas north carolina i just couldn't
get over it he was at midfield and i
literally ran up to him was like holy
crap i didn't realize you were this you
know effin big and i said all those
swear words and everything that i do
okay i had a same
interaction with coleas campbell i was
with the tennessee titans it was early
in his career maybe his second year
there are the arizona cardinals we're
training against them in training camp
and i ran out into practice because
we're going to practice against him that
day and he was right there and i was
like oh my gosh this is kaleis campbell
now i understand i just couldn't get
over the size of you man so what's up
nice to see you again
yeah you know i don't know why but ever
since i was a kid they always want me to
get the bus first
trying to attempt at the team my guest
man i bet
at what age did you become so much
bigger than everyone else
uh so i started high school at six feet
and going into my sophomore year i was
six eight but i've always been like you
know the tallest kid in my class but
sophomore year is when i really took off
go ahead mike go ahead you want to keep
it going
yeah uh and by the way let's point out
if you can't tell from watching the show
kalei is here on behalf of our friends
at old spice i got my old spice on today
i wear my old spice every day i have my
old spice t-shirt on yesterday so we're
always happy to have some folks here on
behalf of old spice
you're in the ravens facility today and
this is your first year with the team
you've been around the league you've
seen a lot of things you've heard a lot
of things how does this team this
organization everything about it stand
out to you based on your time with it so
far it's a special place it really is
you know i feel like one of the best
things you know to have that mentality
of play like a raven uh but the
organization allows you to be yourself
and the best version of yourself and
they really do a great job of arming you
with the tools for you to go out there
and kind of just be who you are and try
to be the best version of yourself so
you can help the team be you know a
great team and you know there's a reason
why this team is always in it at the end
of the year and it really comes down to
to the organization up top and
the coaching and leadership
and then just having the right kind of
guys who buy in you know time and time
again have you been a part of any
culture like this i mean i know you've
been with the cardinals the jaguars team
that went to the afc championship game
that i kind of want to ask you about
like what happened to that team but has
anything compared to this type of
culture that you've been to uh so far in
your career
i feel like we've had moments and we're
trying to build that other places
uh but it's hard i mean this culture to
consistently be this way uh really takes
uh the right kind of people in the
building
and uh and it's a process but uh you
know the ravens have done a really good
job but i think it really starts with
coach harbaugh i mean i'm sure even
above him you know with uh with the
ownership and steve bashady uh but
harbaugh does a really good job of just
allowing players to be themselves uh
communication and uh really allowing us
to thrive and i've had really good
coaches at other places and you've had
we've had moments where everybody bought
in and uh you know really tried to
establish a culture that was special and
uh but it really is hard but you have to
really take your hat off to the people
that came before us with the ravens i i
mean ray lewis and reed and those guys
that came before us really established a
culture that is followed to this day
that allows us to you know go out there
and play like a raven which allows us to
be successful
calais you got a taste of the super bowl
as a rookie with the cardinals in 2008
almost got back a few years ago with the
jaguars how much of that drives you now
there's so many things you can't control
it's a team sport but how much of that
desire to get to a super bowl and when
it is pushing you at this stage of your
career
oh it's my it's my only goal my only
real goal you know uh
i feel like um you know everybody walks
around you know
and you have your championship moments
you have those times you're in your uh
in your mind where you're just like i
know and deep inside that i'm a champion
at heart and you know i just don't have
the hardware i don't have those moments
and
outside of my body yet and so you know
being able to come to the ravens and be
a part of this organization and players
here we have right now you know you feel
like this is uh this is my best
opportunity i'm going to have and we
really have to embrace it and get lost
in the moment and uh capitalize on it
and that's hard to do obviously you know
i mean everybody who's played football
knows to win the championship is a very
very hard thing to do
but this this team has all the pieces in
place and we put ourselves in position
and uh you know i'm excited for the
journey well i mean that's where i want
to go like you know this journey this
year like how did this come about did
you think you might be on the trading
block in jacksonville were there
conversations there did you get to steer
yourself
towards the baltimore ravens i'm just
interested to see kind of how that the
relationship started
yeah no uh honestly um you know there
was there was no real inkling that i
could i was gonna trade it at all you
know and then um you know uh uh
dave caldwell called me and was like hey
hey you know uh you know a couple guys
made some offers that we couldn't refuse
and
you know there's a lot of teams
interested but i feel like baltimore was
was the best win-win for all of us
and so uh we're training to the
baltimore ravens as long as uh you know
it's contingent on the deal being done
you have until you know sunday you know
this is like a friday and so uh we you
know had a couple calls with my agent he
was talking with eric decosta
and uh you know uh i mean my agent was
pretty adamant that uh we can get more
money elsewhere because there were other
teams interested if they didn't come up
and i'm like nah whatev whatever we can
get get the best you can but i want to
be a raven right
hey calais we want to focus on the
future and it's a bright one for you and
the ravens but i am fascinated as is
chris by what happened in jacksonville
so close to the super bowl a couple of
years ago you lived it you were in the
middle of it what's happened there
that's caused a team that was on the
cusp of greatness to fall apart so
quickly
you know i feel like it's a matter of a
few things i mean first of all it's hard
to consistently win an nfl
and uh we were a really young team and i
feel like one of the biggest things that
you know you're always trying to get you
know each team is always trying to get
you know uh bigger stronger faster and
usually younger
and um
and i feel like we lost a couple of blue
chip players that you know might have
been just you know okay on the football
field but where you know for monumental
in the locker room and uh you know two
guys that really come to my mind is uh
paul puzneski and mercedes-lewis losing
those two guys were really hurt the
locker room a little bit because
you know they were just those uh those
those leaders you know they weren't
really vocal as much more as they were
just a example of what to do on a daily
basis and to kept everybody in checking
the line and then you replace them with
younger uh more talented guys and you
know they have to go to their growing
pains
uh we were a team that was you know just
you know we were really really talented
in 2018 and had all the expectations
that started fast and then we you know
we stumbled awesome adversity and our
leadership really uh
you know we didn't have enough of it you
know and those big moments and then just
once it started snowballing it went
downhill and then uh you know we saw
losing talent left and right and
i mean
this is how it goes
hey we know we got to let you go but
before you go you got to give everyone
your old spice pitch you don't have to
convince us we're old spice users tell
everyone else why they should be too
well you know what it really comes down
to it is old spice has really made a
commitment to trying to be more involved
in the community and they made a 10-year
commitment to try to raise the
graduation rate across the united states
of america
and in doing so uh we're promoting the
black voice film the documentary uh i
watch this incredible film and it's
really to encourage
uh all of us uh you know especially
black men to just uh to have
self-confidence and reassurance and and
belief and hope that you know you can go
out and do great things you know and
better than just sports but just uh you
know in life and uh and it starts with
you know just uh somebody believing in
them so all spices took the initiative
to really try to
show young black african-american men
that uh they believe in them and uh
they're going to invest in the future
excellent stuff calais congratulations
on walter payton man of the year all the
best this year as you chase the super
bowl and we'll be waiting for that first
ballot hall of fame
uh induction
hopefully appreciate it you're gonna get
there are you talking to elias good luck
man all right
for sure there he is
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports